[Musique]
bien oui avant de je veux dire ainsi
qu'à il ya un mec m'a envoyé un e-mail
qui s'appelle est dit est dit les
mistons émission elle passe trop tard
j'aurai ce soir france 2 c'est pas ma
faute c'est le pas trop tard il me dit
des fois je m'endors et hindi réveil moi
ai dit voilà on m'a demandé de le faire
donc je le fais edit réveille toi
alors attention lardy vous êtes prêts ce
ne sera pas pire que nathan thierry pour
eddy savoie
là on est sûr on est sûr ce sera pas
pire que la finale contre les amerloques
vous pensez à quoi là mon fils ouais il
me dit quoi le matin en vous regardant
dans un miroir qui je dois aller
m'entraîner
ouais si vous fêtiez non mais vous
bossez chien matin c'est pas toujours
évident gc oui vous lui ressemblez à qui
quand vous étiez petit mon père pourquoi
pas ce que ton fils unique j'ai toujours
mis sur un piédestal et toujours essayer
de ressembler ce qui vous a fait le plus
mal comme insulte radin et parada en
fait du tout quand vous tour on vous
demande des autographes
écrivez quoi le rad lolo et mon numéro
c'est tout à votre numéro de téléphone
dans mon numéro de maillot avant quand
le téléphone sonne vous êtes heureux ou
angoissé heureux 1
l'idéologie qui vous fait bander j'ai
pas alex et le socialisme joker part
d'un joker
qu'est ce qui faisait le plus
indispensable pour vous endormir
tu call un prix pas pourquoi je vais
vous endormir son canal affiche y suit
dépend des fois mais pas une seule des
fois on est passé à donner à sydney
comment ça se passe dans un village la
balle assez fatigue lassitude la fatigue
le podcasting ya pas maman là non bien
qu'en avez vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois aux jo à sydney quand vous avez
gagné
quand on est gagnant à caen 10 caressais
quand on a gagné la demi-finale contre
l'australie
ah oui et pour la compte les américains
faisaient pas mal non non parce que
quelque part on est sûr d'avoir une
médaille elle restait plus à savoir
laquelle pas qu'elle souhaitait si
c'était à refaire votre vie qu'est ce
que vous feriez pas pareil je conçois
même chose exactement là exactement la
même chose et vous seriez ici ce soir
oui et pourquoi
[Musique]
c'est thierry tu m'a pas cru la dernière
fois mais bien sûr que la france gronde
et la france est au bord de l'implosion
et ailleurs des manifestations
les gens ne comprennent pas pourquoi pas
le bouger et toi tu leur dis pas
vraiment séduit parce que le jury parce
que là ça les gens mais menace de bouger
pendant jingle si je vais parce qu'ils
disent donc si tu veux un jour je
t'emmènerai un bug et mon intime
conviction je te sens et non mais c'est
vrai bien alors en faire une hardy view
vous pensez quoi le matin quand vous
regarder dans un miroir et je ne me
regarde pas un miroir parce que je dors
à bord ce qui me fait le plus mal comme
insulte abri à une fois un petit gars à
l'école maladie est sale [ __ ]
grâce à samassa pourrait enfin comme je
disais ça là bas c'était à cayenne non
ici à paris
à paris un bail il ya les rôles vous
avez souffert non pas du tout jamais dû
souffert du racisme
non et vous pensez aujourd'hui par
exemple qu'il ya beaucoup de mouvements
qui disent qu'à la télévision on voit
pas assez les namas c'est votre bonne
punk est venu calixthe beyala quand vous
pensez quoi sérieusement avec ne pas
penser me suis là parce qu'elle n'est
pas contente elle dit qu'il n'y a pas
assez de gens de couleur les pas de
message mais ça dépend je crois que je
crois qu'il faut du talent donc ne
changeriez quoi si vous aviez une
baguette magique
ah bah vous le dire
[Applaudissements]
c'est par la réputation vous avez un qui
avez vous qui avez vous le plus envie de
des pâtés à moi c'est tout c'est le
public le public qui a pas quelqu'un
auprès de vous vous dites j'ai vraiment
envie de l'épaté sur les gens en général
c'est toute la nation parce que c'est un
métier
vous savez un métier c'est un artiste
c'est un métier où ils nous on doit
toujours étonné c'est à dire que je vous
faites un tour de chant cette année si
vous faites le même l'année prochaine
mais plus rien ouais il faut épaté il
faut trop et tu as pété à la vie
publique
le péché qui vous tente le plus quand le
téléphone sonne vous êtes heureux ou
angoissé et je ne réponds jamais parce
que voilà et moi j'ai une copine qui est
folle folle du téléphone je lui en a
offert ailleurs et elle dira je suis
content quand on téléphone
ça veut dire qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
pense à moi moi je dis à chaque fois que
le téléphone sonne c'est un non merde
alors je vous ai c'est henri stoll alors
est ce que vous êtes fait pour un
quatrième mariage
non mais sans enterrement rassure moi
ouais non mais je suis marié trois fois
et sont morts tous les trois les trois
alors oui j'ai peur j'ai peur j'ai c'est
parce que la femme avec qui je suis je
les aime beaucoup et je veux pas qu'elle
meure ne vous est pas parce qu on sait
pas ce qu on est superstitieux et les
artistes
[Musique]
bien si laurent baffie n'est pas la
semaine prochaine on saura pourquoi
regarder
oui ça va j'attends patiemment
j'aimerais bien savoir je suis très bien
oui et vous même ça va très bien bah
tant mieux il finit le monsieur je
termine le plombage et après on passe
bien vous vous dites quoi le matin quand
vous voyez devant un miroir
les gars à qui voulez vous ressembler
quand vous étiez petit à personne à moi
même si post il aimerait vous n'aviez
pas d'idole non pas du tout
qu'est ce qui vous énerve le plus chez
vous chez moi ma façon de marché va
regarder le dos est trop raide enfin bon
c'est paraîtrait qu est ce qui vous
énerve le plus chez days c'est de la
coiffure
j'étais chez bâti charles qu'est ce qui
vous énerve le plus sanon coiffure chez
moi ça trop bien joie fusent
ça veut dire qu'on se donne du mal à y a
pas je veux qu'ils bull soit deux eurent
bien est ce que vous seriez prêt à tout
quitter pour le grand amour
non non c'est rare je me dis oui en
général
bah oui pas moi si vous restez 24 heures
à vivre feriez quoi l'amour
c'est une question parce que non parce
que temps si on sait qu'on a 24 heures à
vivre
on continue espérer que ce sera plus
donc ça croyez moi on ne dit pas ça on
l'acceptait pas bon mais j'aimerais te
poser cette question alors non alors
attendez benjamin castaldi du nord puis
la faune et c'est génial on avoir
discuté les questions à mais sachant
qu'elle est la dernière chose que vous
faites avant de vous coucher
l'amour les cantines sol quand je suis
tout seul amour
non je mets les dents dans un verre à me
les gentils alors attention
charles berling vous changeriez courant
vous si vous aviez une baguette magique
par le pull pourquoi il est pas beau j
ai bien pourquoi
non ben moi j'ai c'est la connerie vous
disent rien mais j'ai tourné sans tapis
sont peu les dépanneurs ça marche et là
ça bouge pas je partage il dit des
choses que je ne pense pas qu'on veuille
bien lui parce qu'il faut justifier un
quota de conneries
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous allez partir sur le petit bateau
beige beige dans le mobil home
non mais la belge en mode vidéo
et toi dans le bateau et nous salue que
la cote comme ça vaille d'accord ok est
ce qu'il peut attendre deux minutes
l'asile parce qu'elle est surtout quand
vous a donné que vous allez y sans pull
marron avant le non sens bien on était
déjà la question le surnom qu'on vous a
donné que vous haïssez beaucoup des
trucs comme ça et bahreïn ne sais pas si
l'idée d'un coup oui enfin quant à moi
s'appelait génitif un peu comme ça alors
là moi j'aime savoir les clients jusqu'à
le péché qui vous tente le plus la
luxure quoi raconte comment la luxure
genre là ouais déjà quand j'étais petit
on me disait que j'étais pervers qu'il
était moche ouais ouais on peut devenir
que par un tous les deux chats on ne
bouge pas pendant le jingle en ligne
[Musique]
c'est mardi view
[Applaudissements]
mais
l'union bouliste et mat et laissez moi
faire les efforts si à la fin il ne fait
pas le gage qui sera écrivain sera une
couille molle
ok muriel vous pensez à quoi la cha
ouais vous pensez à quoi
à rien souvent je pense rien - allez
vous être agréable bouddhiste sens et je
crois est naturellement mais parfois
très bon comme c'est une petite vous lui
ressemblez à qui je voulais être jésus
davantage chanter que c'est et ça ça
qu'on m'avait envoyé pour sauver le
monde après il sentit c'était un peu
trop de boulot donc donc de jésus j'ai
dû passer annie girardot si oui alors je
voulais te l'a examiné lui tout ça où je
dis pas très attiré par sa queue ce qui
vous énerve le plus chez vous on vous
annonce aimé énervement je crois que ça
va mieux beaucoup mieux qu'est ce qui
vous énerve le plus chez moi
non c'est parfois quand vous souriez
j'ai pas les sculptant les yeux avec je
me dis sourit vraiment ils sourient pas
si quand j'ai pas quand ça marche c'est
le j'adore
cela dit le marché parce qu'il est
méchant
qu'est ce qui vous a fait le plus mal
comme insulte répond [ __ ] sa j'adore
non c'est quand on me dit mais chante on
l'a dit pas souvent on me l'a écrit une
fois non méchant mais où se cache du
mariage avec le noir et à quelqu'un qui
m'a écrit qui a pensé qui m'a insulté
m'a dit que c'était très méchant de
celle de prendre de l'argent faisait de
l'argent sur le dos des noirs bon que
dans vos demandes d'autographes vous
écrivez quoi alors ça alors c'est très
bizarre parce que bizarrement j'ai écrit
mes robes ah c'était ça il n'y a pas une
gradation mettait pas amitié quand c'est
vraiment difficile chez cent de la
demande lâcher ses enfants j'ai peur de
penser qu est ce que vous pourriez
suivons rester 24 heures à vivre 24
heures 24 heures du mans 24 heures non
moi je pense à rien je ferais rien su de
cette virée chez ikea je montrais un
meuble quant au long terme
ban car c'est quand est-ce que vous avez
joué pour la dernière fois mais pour
quelle raison parce que parce que le
saviez vous venez ici aujourd'hui parce
qu'elle fume sortait sa a fait une sorte
de décompression voilà c'est une fatigue
dernière personne que vous ayez eu envie
de tuer j'ai pas envie de tuer s'est pas
montrée même pas quand même de temps en
temps vraiment je vais à la poste ou à
sécu nom de la foi c'est un truc voilà
me tuer mais je sais vous que c'est trop
difficile dans l'équité le monde il ya
la finale c'était à refaire votre vie
vous feriez quoi pas pareil ce serait de
la musique ça c'est sûr ah oui c'est à
ce point là et jouer du piano quand même
à waimes rien enfin ah bon non je serai
avec la musique que ça vraiment y'a pas
la guitare batterie tout devriez le
faire
les déjà pensé au suicide oui oui ça non
les autres légumes intérêts oui pour
dojo du club y est positif est si 12ème
un peu je te laisse de trois lames de
rasoir
je regarde ce qu'ils vont faire mais
vraiment est-ce que vous organisez rien
d'inné où on parle pas de vous
[Applaudissements]
on ne bouge pas
le king a très bien j'ai l'habitude de
ne pas bouger parce qu'à la messe aussi
à des noirs bouche pas un moment on doit
baisser la tête et tout donc c'est un
peu pareil finalement ces espèces de
grandes messes ici le samedi soir vous
pensez à quoi là bas je vous disais
c'est une espèce de je disais oui de
liturgie vous vous dites quoi le matin
quand vous vous voyez en miroir j'évite
de me regarder à ce moment là ce qui
vous énerve le plus en vous la chose que
vous supportez le mois chez vous ma
gueule pourquoi qu'est ce que la ta
gueule parce que non parce que parce que
c'est tellement l'objet tellement été
l'objet de deux colis b de toutes sortes
que pourquoi elle préférerait avoir
quelques visages plus anonymes alors
mais vous avez vous avez une tête pour
faire de la télé à tomber l'arrêter
écoutez j'ai belle tête d'acteur je te
dirai pour moi mais c'est vrai mais
c'est bien quand on descend berlin est
ce que vous seriez prêt à tout quitter
pour le grand amour alors imaginer non
mais sérieusement à vous rencontrer une
fille comme ça est ce que vous seriez
prêt à abandonner votre état de prêtres
vous l'imaginez ça y est vous qui vous
savez maintenant c'est très difficile de
se projeter dans cette situation-là à
froid à froid là je vais vous dire non
mais je n'ai pas peur mais bien sûr que
ça peut arriver
je ne feriez tout quitter pour le grand
amour je ne sais pas ouais bah vous dit
pas non qu'est ce que vous faites la
dernière chose que vous faites avant de
vous coucher le soir je vais regarder
mes messages sur internet reste plus que
moderne
si c'était à refaire votre vie vous
referiez la même chose oui oui je ferai
le même choix que celui que j'ai fait
dire la même chose à la filiale à
l'époque de louis 17 ans vous regrettez
pas ça non quel est le péché qui vous
tente le plus mais ça je le réserve à
mon professeur
vous ne pensez pas que prometteur même
si je me prête sa voix malgré tous mes
efforts je n'arrive pas à confesser mon
souvenir du palco merci beaucoup en tous
les cas merci de votre
j'ai dit bon bout je crois cependant le
guignol comme réponse de thierry
addition vous pensez à quoi là quand ton
char de scène on a encore tous ces gens
qui vous applaudissent que british à
dieu devant vous c'est femme nue qui
viennent devant vous offrir des fleurs
qui vous regardent le fan c'est le
bonheur c'est sa femme
vous dites quoi le matin quand vous
voyez dans le miroir non non non non de
j'me dis je suis moche mais mais mais
c'est pas grave parce que dans disons
adieu la lettre r enfin l'assemblée où
est ce steve austin
lorsque je faisais je m'amusais quand je
venais de voir un film de steve austin
hors jeu ma mère me dit tu vas chercher
qu'est ce que tu veux aller chercher du
lait oqali je prenais je connais les 400
francs et je courrai et je faisais la
bande son que j'ai tonton de tan tan tan
tan tan
vous écrivez quoi quand on vous demande
des autographes
allez vous faire [ __ ] tirèrent disent
on vous feriez quoi si vous restez 24
heures à vivre 24 heures je regarderai
les casse tête que j'ai pas eu le temps
de regarder la dernière chose que vous
faites avant de vous coucher
dernière chose je fais le coucher du
film publiait lycée marie vierge marie
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît faites
du chirec soit pourrie
quelle est la phrase que vous ne
supportez pas d'entendre faites-moi des
imitations
à chaque question quand avez vous pleuré
pour la dernière fois à j'ai pleuré
il n'y a pas très longtemps
mais à chaudes larmes un film magnifique
ce petit enfant qui apprend à danser
billy elia voilà c'est à ce film là que
j'ai pleuré pour la dernière fois et
celle d'avant c'était la vie est belle
avec b bravo la dernière personne que
vous ayez eu envie de tuer quelqu'un moi
j'aime tout le monde je dis merci à tout
le monde
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est mon avis le surnom qu'on vous
donne que vous haïssez imitateurs ouais
le plombier comme près de 10 me tâte
hors jeu bolt j'ai pas bien répondu à la
question je suis d'accord aujourd'hui
l'avenir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en rouge par zynga
alors c'est la review par exemple
première question à quoi vous pensez la
question que vous allez me posais qui
m'inquiète nom vous dit quoi le matin
quand vous regardez dans le miroir rien
je suis allé prendre un café et rien ne
dit pas c'est bien tu es moche tu sais
de quoi les jours mais je sais pas j'ai
pas une réflexion profonde profonde
quand vous étiez petite vie ressemble à
qui a une copine de classe que je
trouvais absolument sublimissime tepa de
leva talibans et en même temps qu'est ce
qui vous énerve le plus chez vous la
patience
chez moi vous aimez le plus peut-être la
patience aussi d'accord
quelle insulte qui vous a fait le plus
mal cogent une de mes forces et
d'oublier les trucs
pas bien moi j'ai pas envie de
m'encombrer ça alors il y en a
certainement sur le couple qui m'ont
fait du mal mais jugent ils m'en fous
j'ai oublié je suis resté 24 avis vous
feriez quoi tirer sous un grand
châtaignes et est en phase de ma maison
dans le centre de la france avec ma
fille je joue bien avec lui et toujours
cette maison c'est souvent là bas dans
la creuse c'est un nom qui est la
dernière personne que vous ayez envie de
tuer un type qui m'a collé à l'autoroute
avec la voiture et je trouve que ces
mecs qui sont au volant et qu'ils
veulent vous doublez qui vous colle
comme ça c'est le seul moment où je peux
avoir envie de tuer comprenez vous
connecter oui mais comme tient aussi à
toi vous changeriez courant vous si vous
avez une baguette magique
écoutez j'ai mis très longtemps à
m'accepter alors maintenant ça y est que
c'est trop tard pour la baguette
si c'était à refaire vivre que ce cas
que vous ne feriez pas pareil je
reprenne tout pareil débat erreur parce
que si on commence à dire des trucs
comme ça on s'en sortent pas et et puis
les erreurs c'est ce qui vous fait
avancer aussi qui avez vous le plus
envie d'épater
moi j'ai déjà pensé au suicide
non quel péché qui nous tente le plus
[Musique]
petit que ça pour faire plaisir non
choix alors si c'est sincère sans peur
quand le téléphone sonne vous êtes
heureuse ou agacé je ne sais pas mais
dans notre métier souvent entre 11
heures et 13 heures 15
c'est infernal et entre 18 heures et 10
heures ils se réveillent d'henri salles
art après vous appelle et un appartement
j'ai bien compris on peut vous appeler
hacker leur savoir camita d'accord vous
avez menti pendant cette interview non
et maintenant une petite hardy ou yves
parlier
dans le bon sens bien on ne bouge pas
rigueur
quand vous étiez à l'école vous étiez un
petit peu dyslexique et asocial et je
vois que ça continue vous avez bougé
pendant le jingle à une message me sèye
pas on va recommencer on rallume la
bouche
de ces chiens jamais oui alors aux
idiots ils parliez vous pensez à quoi là
avoue oui nous en aller à la question
vous avez vous pouvez très bien la
question et vous dites quoi le matin
qu'on voyait dans un miroir tel boom à
eux qu'elle boom
est-ce qu'il faut que je me rase matin
ouais comme vous étiez petit bougé
ressemble et acquis un peu plus tard que
petit eric tabarly quand j'étais petit à
personne est ce que vous êtes déjà senti
le maître du monde
oui oui quand
quand j'étais à califourchon en haut de
mon mât sûr qu'à collègues d'aquitaine
ouais je m'étais vraiment assis comme ça
et je me disais j'ai toute la planète
autour de moi pour don va durer dix
secondes après ses crocs il est descendu
de rêver les yeux déjà senti une sous
merde à la fin de la construction de mon
premier bateau aquitaine était tellement
épuisée déprimé que je rêvais d'être un
facteur anonyme sans aucune
responsabilité
je rencontre les familles à l'heure mais
je l'avais je les avais beaucoup
plombier à ça qu'est ce que ça fait le
plus mal comme insultes il ya peu de
temps on m'a dit que j'avais perdu
toutes mes chances pour le vendée globe
ça ça m'a fait mal et
c'est peut-être aussi pour ça que j'ai
continué ouais alors comme il est tout à
leur bon évidemment il ya eu des joyaux
il ya de macarthur mais vous êtes quand
même l' aventure de vendée globe on vous
demande beaucoup de beaucoup
d'autographes vous écrivez quoi quand on
vous demande un autographe
j'imagine je signe juste et je vais dit
excusez moi j'ai pas le temps il m'a
marqué vous même ah oui c'est ça si vous
aviez 24 heures à vivre
vous feriez quoi si vous restez 24
heures à vivre chez a fait un peu de
bateaux c'est banal
le dernière chose que vous faites avant
de vous coucher je respire par le ventre
et je décontracte les muscles
à 26 ans sa première fois qu'on me
reprocher je vous fait vous respirer par
le ventre
il
[Applaudissements]
ça vous a fait du bien là quand avez
vous pleuré pour la dernière fois je
pense au large du brésil
ouais lui ici toi là-bas vous changeriez
quoi on vous si vous aviez une baguette
magique je crois que je sais pas
remercier les gens qui y mène autour de
moi ouais là profitez en ça que j'étais
la tv merci les gars
l'ifi un way qui avez vous le plus envie
d'épater mes confrères navigateur vous
déjà pensé au suicide
ouais sur le bateau là bas non non non
ça remonte vraiment un très très bon à
terre le péché qui vous tente le plus la
daurade ponctuelles devant la presse et
empêché valve apparaissent sur un bateau
il ya pas des jours on lit de rien
[ __ ] comme messi mais ça en fait je
suis content les derniers jeux excusez
moi dans la rue
vous savez qu'on ne bouge pas avant le
jingle est un morceau on ne bouge pas
ou bien on pense à quoi là maintenant
présentement mais je pense que le
chauffeur de taxi m'a dit quelque chose
de drôle en fait quand il m'a dit qu'ils
ont dressé ces gosses quand est arrivé à
la maison ce soir
et chez nous les gosses et les couilles
[Applaudissements]
quand vous étiez petits bouts de
ressembler à qui voulait être noir avec
comme nino ferrer sprint ce qui vous
énerve le plus chez vous en vous je
portais pas ma timidité
chaque incident si mignon ça se boit tu
as l'air un grand timide timide quoi
dans vos poches là quelques freins dans
la poche gauche et qu'est ce que j'ai
fait je savais que j'avais quelque chose
ici j'ai des vitamines
oui si 3 vitamines que la personne est
vital au camembert
qu'avez-vous fait que nous ne sachions
pas j'ai fait un spectacle à la dernière
de céline dion avait invité à faire un
rap avec elle et puis j'ai rapper avec
ses enfants c'était la dernière son show
qu'il a fait pour l'an 2000 sur mini
lendemain de l'arrivée
et puis je faisais un rap je fermais mes
yeux pour me concentrer sur le texte je
fais des moves à la blague comme ça et
s'approcher d'eux est tombé sur scène
non la fed
vous avez venger d'une certaine façon
atlantis vous feriez quoi s'il vous
restait 24 heures à lire
je pense que j'en mourrais à benoît joly
répond et vous pleurez pour la dernière
fois
sérieusement j'ai pleuré à paris cette
semaine
pourquoi il ya deux jours mais moi je
suis assez en fait il est tout seul
non mais ça nous donne envie d'être
maniaco dépressif mais en fait c'est
parce que en examen à paris
ça va faire une peut-être mais j'avais
déjà vu un album de brel et ça faisait
longtemps que j'avais pas écouté puis
j'ai mis ça dans moi dans mon disque man
puis je marchais dans paris a demandé il
fait la tournée de la chanson jeff wade
c'est terrible quand sa part un
manifeste un périple cette bonne image
qu'il faisait beau des pv
quelle est la dernière personne que vous
ayez envie de tuer à part ces unions
non je suis pas violent pas du tout non
tant avec les bras que vous avez vous
pouvez parier là non non non non ça
c'est c'est juste ça tient mon père grou
tatouages sur les bras une espèce de
coeur avec les classiques de l'époque le
coeur avec le dag dit pas oui c'est beau
serpent qui tourne the rocker avec un
dragon qui crache des flammes sur une
fermette qui brûla guitton qui m'ont
encore il a à ma mère mon père il a
coupé si vous en voyez quoi en vous et
si vous aviez une baguette magique non
changerait peut-être effectivement un
titeuf va planter là dessus mais mon
côté timide et je rigole et ça me tape
jamais essayé de faire du spectacle
parce que souvent les timides il faut
une bonne thérapie s'est tout de suite
bien depuis le début d'émission elle est
comme ça au tutorat
[Musique]
déjà oui le péché qui vous tente le plus
ben moi j'aime la gourmandise moi j'aime
bien le gâteau je suis timide des
gâteaux de question et la réponse la
prochaine du stuff vous savez qu'on ne
bouge pas pour le jingle on vous l'a dit
on avoue charles dans le lignage
[Musique]
quoi l'autre je crois mais qu'est ce qui
se passe mais j'ai dans le public pourra
commencer à fait gérable dans le public
tu t'approches de sept cas pas de
culotte sur tout non non non non non non
elle et elle est élue l'espoir d' idiot
vous pensez à quoi là j'ai toujours
tendance à penser un petit peu à la
halle à la seconde qui bien que c'est le
plus beau moment de la miss et c'est la
seconde équipe de déséquilibre est
toujours vers la seconde suivante oui
quand vous regardez le matin dans votre
mémoire vous vous dites quoi
j'aime bien non même avant d'ailleurs
j'aimais bien regarder dans les vitrines
ouais parce que il ya des vitrines dans
paris et des endroits qu'on connaît et
djelfa compassion
oui il ya des belleville oui un elias
est un plaisir alors que tous les matins
différent quand j'ai eu l'habitude c'est
chiant quand à dire regardez tous les
matins ne vous étiez petit milliards
semblait qui marquent la taille à la
marilyn monroe à l'oubliette marilyn
monroe
c'est bon ça les cheveux comme ça non
c'est pas dit si tu veux c'est que j'ai
quand j'étais petit j'étais tellement
jamais tellement les photos de marilyn
monroe j'aimais tellement il est filmé
que aujourd'hui si vous me posez cette
question j'ai pas un gm plus vraiment un
ces ressembler mais aliments droite
aurait aimé avoir des gros nichons fait
aborder la terre entière ouais ouais
mais non non juste il veut des greniers
je me permets de l'emec des promos du
tout on a bien tenté un christophe quand
avez vous pleuré pour la dernière fois
l'impression que tout le temps pleurer
mais en fait en fait comme les com mais
mais mais mes larmes coulent vers
l'intérieur ça ne se voit pas à quoi
hein quel péché qui vous tente le plus
l'éclair au chocolat
ça c'est si c'était à refaire la vie
vous feriez quoi pas pareil mais je
crois que je crois que je ferais
vraiment j'ai livré mon rêve le plus le
but le plus profond c'est c'est le
voilier donc je crois que tout que très
très tôt un j'aurais appris très tôt à
ce qu'ils cassent ce qui peuvent et puis
pour pouvoir me barrer joris de loore
antoine peut-être n'y a pas vraiment
vide et antoine mais j'aurais plutôt
envie de lui mettre un coup d'arrêt la
tête pour lui voler son bateau voilà
quelle insulte qui vous a fait le plus
mal en toi qui viennent le dire qu'elle
est la dernière chose que vous faites le
soir avant de vous coucher découpage
vous est découpée quoi par exemple cette
semaine à cette semaine voilà j'ai dit
j'ai découpé ça enfin cette semaine en
deux soirs ouais en gros je patine voilà
j'ai découpé sur pen sur pen
sean penn ouais trucs sur en gros un way
mars à la moitié des coloriages
ouais plein plein toujours ce petit
dossier comme ça me fait toujours avec
vous tant attendu
j'écris tout le temps il veut revenir un
truc fait souvent si bon c j'ai toujours
besoin d'une petite friandise amant
avant de m'endormir et donc jeu j'aime
bien les fils est aussi trop ah bon
c'est marrant ce que la dernière
personne que vous ayez envie de tuer
peut pas répondre un tu avais 14 douanes
pour lui voler son bateau mais oui mais
oui mais c'est tout quoi je veux dire a
fait deux fois qu'on dit antoine chez
les n'alerte est ce que vous êtes déjà
pensé au suicide christophe salut dans
mes rêves de glace et le traverser mais
je pense que pour aller au bout
je pense qu'il faut être très fort et
moi je suis très faible christophe est
ce que vous avez menti pendant cette
interview
bien sûr que oui
[Musique]